in August of 2017 the destroyer USS John
McCain was involved in a devastating
collision with a merchant ship off
Singapore ten sailors aboard the McCain
died in the mishap now their families
have decided to proceed with legal
action but not against the US Navy they
say it's to keep the owners of the other
ship from evading responsibility Kris
Van Cleave has the story
it has ripped me from stem to stern
when Kevin booth shell was laid to rest
last fall it was just the beginning of
the pain sorrow and anger for his father
Tom this horrible tragedy that is
totally unnecessary it killed me
last August the USS McCain lost steering
in the Singapore Strait one of the
world's busiest shipping lanes the Navy
destroyer veered into the path of the
Olenick a tanker ship the early morning
collision killed 10 sailors aboard the
McCain including Kevin oil chemicals
fuel oil all in that water just holding
his breath that would have started
burning I mean it would been in torture
a navy report placed blame on some of
the McCain's crew saying they weren't
aware of their surroundings and failed
to properly steer the ship and an
investigation by Singapore's Ministry of
Transport pointed out mistakes by the
Olenick the report called the onyx
actions to avoid collision insufficient
investigators found the onyx bridge
where the ship is controlled was
understaffed at the time of the accident
it also revealed the Olenick was on
autopilot and did not slow down until
moments before impact they both were at
fault
Rachel Echols son Timothy also died on
the McCain we need answers from both
sides knuckles and Michelle learned the
owner of the Olenick is petitioning in
federal court to be cleared of all
liability or to have it's liability
limited when I first saw the papers I
looked at him I was kind of dumped I
mean I didn't I didn't know what I was
looking at the Onyx owner cites a law
that predates the Civil War called the
ship owners limitation of Liability Act
of 1851 under the law the onyx potential
damages will be capped at 16 point seven
million dollars that's the onyx value
after
the collision it was like a second
double slap in our face it was literally
like are you kidding me you are a part
of this tragedy and you're gonna come
after us and say well this is what
because of ruling from 1851 this is all
that you can do it's mind-boggling
it can represents nine of the McCain
victims families why should I look have
any hand in liability here when even the
Navy says this was an accident
created by mistakes made on the McCain
the Navy is doing things to make sure
this does not happen again but whenever
you have an incident like this there's
accountability on both sides the victims
families are planning to challenge the
ship owners petition so is the Navy but
they will need to prove the all decks
actions weren't just a sailing error but
also that management was at fault
everybody is always surprised to learn
about limitation of Liability Professor
Martin Davies is the director of Tulane
University's maritime law center he says
the law was originally passed to
stimulate the risky business of sea
train this kind of litigation is
absolutely typical after a major
incident such as this for the past at
least 150 years the whole economic
structure of the shipping business has
been premise to pond limited liability
the limitation Act has been used before
by ship owners after high-profile
accidents like the Titanic in the
sinking of the El Faro do you feel like
you're getting victimized again by an
arcane law it's someone trying to use
whatever law they can find on the books
whether just or not to try to eliminate
or limit their liability the company
that owns the Olenick declined our
requests for comment but is suing the
Navy for damages to its ship we asked
the lawyer for the McCain families if
they intend to sue the Navy he told us
that many of them are uncomfortable with
the idea of suing the institution their
family members dedicated their lives to
her CBS this morning Kris Van Cleave
Washington just prolonged pain for these
families it's so hard to see
and like they're being victimized again
the yeah